CAROLINA HURRICANES DI AROUND 25
CHANCES BUT THE EDMONTON OILERS
DO GET QUALIFY
ABLE TO STEER THAT ONE ON BEAR D
ETHAN BEAR, A LONGELD, AROUND
THE NET HERE AND OUTT WITH IT.
BROKEN UP THAT TIME BY TO BRAD
HUNT WHO HASREE TO CHATFIELD ANT
IS A PASS TO TERAVAINEN, LOOKING
TO RETURN YOU $1 MILLION.
OOD ALL-AROUND PE
OF TO
HUGHES.
THAT CAREER
GOAL AGAINST CAROLINA, THAT WAS
LASTIT IS A CHECK FROM
STAAL, PEARSON, STAAL, BOESER,
BODY, BODY, GETTING POSITION
HERE AND THEN GIVING I STEPAN,
LD
NOW PEARSON WITH AHIS
AFTER HUNT WAS WALKED BY SLAVIN
WITH THE LAST LRS WITH A
QUICK BURST, THE A FINE
PLAY TO ELIAS PETTERSSON TO MAKE
IT 2-0. COACH.
THE YOUNG PLAYER.
KOTKANIEMI.
LEAVING THE P
NOW JARVIS, A WRISTER!IT IS OUTO
MILLER AND CHASING A THE SHAFT
WHO COULD NOT MAKE CONTACT WIT .
AND NOW MYERS. LATE, I GUESS. G?
ELIAS PETTERSSON.
TO GARLAND, THAT BACKHANDER
OVERTOP OF T THE
GOOD FINISH AND A SCRAMBLE HERE,
THERE,
DOWLING AS WELL AND HE HAD HIS E
THERE VERY HARD.
>> John S.: FOR HORVAT, ABLE TO]
>> John S.: AND WITH EXACTLY TWO
SPRAWLING AND AN OPPORTUNITY NOW